yesterday I asked on Twitter at D Pakman
you should be following me by the way
what stories should I definitely cover
on tomorrow's show that being today's
program and I got a bunch of people who
said David you have to talk about how
right-wing host ben shapiro is saying he
doesn't believe brett Cavanaugh's
accusers because they haven't described
Brett Kavanaugh as penis which I assumed
that can't really be what ben shapiro
said but alas it is and the reason i'm
covering this this is not just another
wacky thing ben shapiro said although it
is yet another wacky thing that ben
shapiro said there's actually more to
this so let's let's set it up Brett
Kavanagh has been accused again of
sexual assault
Trump is off the rails tweeting about it
I told you about that earlier this week
and in comes ben shapiro and he says the
reason that he doubts the veracity of
the allegations is that if Cavanaugh had
really sexually assaulted anyone the
victims would have been able to describe
Bret Cavanaugh's penis in detail by now
this apparently counts as an argument in
some circles check that take a look at
the video check it out we've had a bevy
of public figures in recent years who
have had their genitalia described on
national television by people who allege
sexual assault right store McDaniels
famously described president from
genitalia Bill Clinton's genitalia
details of such word talked about nobody
has yet subscribes Cavanaugh's Janet now
that's not dispositive maybe they were
generic who knows but the bottom line is
we've had no corroborating details on
any of these stories all of them
apparently happen in public places with
other witnesses available and not one
witness has been there who corroborates
any of these stories it's unbelievable
and yet the Democrats are still saying
that Cavanaugh should be kicked off the
Supreme Court based on what a new report
from a guy who says that he was at a
party and saw a mail grab Cavanaugh's
penis which by the way would be sexual
assault and then thrust it into the hand
of a female who says she doesn't
remember the incident it's so crazy that
this is the argument that Ben Shapiro is
making for why he doesn't believe the
allegations against Breck have enough
it's almost like he doesn't know how sex
works and I
no he must because he has children right
I mean I don't know much about his
personal life but as far as I know the
the the humans that he calls his kids
are biologically his kids and as far as
far as I would guess they were conceived
in sort of the normal way so you would
imagine he knows how sex works I can't
believe I'm doing this
but there are a few problems with this
argument from ben shapiro first of all
of course is that incidents that happen
at parties sexual assaults all of this
stuff many of these things happen in
dark places like this this is so
rudimentary and fundamental but from a
logistical perspective if something
happens in a dark place you may not have
been able to look at identifying marks
on brett Cavanaugh's genitalia that
doesn't really seem like a big deal it's
not a big counterpoint to any of the
accusers number two in incidents of
trauma victims are often not focusing on
let me see if there are moles or
birthmarks or skin discolorations on
Bret Cavanaugh's genitalia they're
scared for their lives they're being
assaulted and their priority likely is
survival and getting away so once again
not having in mind particular
characteristics of Brett Kavanaugh penis
does not seem to be material in this
case and then maybe most importantly
this is a specious argument argument
because if you can even call it an
argument if a woman did describe Brett
Kavanaugh as penis in her allegation the
defenders would just come up with some
other way to dismiss that point and I
was actually reminded of Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson's pin in Michael Jackson
of course the late pop star who had
multiple allegations of child sexual
assault against him Michael Jackson's
penis was described by accusers and
defenders just came up with excuses I
don't remember exactly what the excuses
were but listen if someone describes
Cavanaugh's penis they could say well
someone could have told them how to
describe it there could be a doctor with
knowledge of his penis who is involved
in the conspiracy or it was a lucky
guess or with Jackson Jackson was known
to have vitiligo the skin condition so
it would be just a safe guest
that his penis also had discolorations
because it's known that he had vitiligo
or whatever the point is you can always
defend it someone describes Cavanaugh's
penis well they could have been in
cahoots with a doctor who saw it once or
the description was too generic or it's
not accurate in some minut irrelevant
way or whatever and by the way I think
the let me link this back now beyond ben
shapiro to really what is the the the
issue the media focus on Cavanaugh's
behavior in high school and college
instead of his lying to congress and his
extraordinarily suspicious financial
transactions may at the higher level be
both misguided and counterproductive but
that's a completely different story so
there's the analysis from ben shapiro he
wants the penis described in detail or
he is going to be skeptical of the
allegations that have been made that
it's that this is 2019 and this is this
is the world that we live in today let's
take a quick break make sure you like
the david pakman show on facebook at
facebook.com slash david pakman show
coming up next a judge has been
permanently barred from the bench for
posting a pro trump magum essage with a
picture of a noose nice right we'll talk
about that after the break i am thrilled
to tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman Blink astiz a really unique
service for your phone tablet and web
browser and it is incredibly useful for
people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to
blankest calm / Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the description I have listened to
blinka spokes about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month go to blink is calm / Pakman
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n